welcome to this video that okay so let's
see what I can do against this GM my
your offer I had played him recently
yeah you shoulda kept her waiting it's
good it's going down again I lost all my
prep games it don't know what it is
check um yeah let's see if the sameish
variation can give me a break here okay
it's playing of halle the fairly odd
fashion set up here that I have yeah
let's say given hit negative remarks
earlier in the earlier games okay let's
see what we get here I always think that
why does quite substantially better here
in this position type where I have not
cancelled yet but ok maybe he gets in a
good locating a good bloke aiding set up
g4 and yes though it's still probably
yeah night tonight coming to g5 but I
still have a very substantial advantage
in space
okay so is this doing very much i can go
nite h5 in this position Queen age for
Bishop of Chang leads nowhere then now I
can go age for even yeah I think I'll do
that this should be useful okay nice
playing this very quickly but I really
don't know if it is any good I go back
to g3 no es night f4 so I probably
should check here and here maybe Bishop
g3 covering f4 h4 is safely protected
yeah this he can do but i'm not sure
what it if it is doing so much great
just queen d tool now taking on d3 is
not really helping him
yeah I can also root g one night age
three that's look everyone so I want to
take care play g5 if this is the the
general idea ok so he allows me to do
that
ok
I take with the pawn Queenie five is
probably okay for black
ok is yes Queen takes g5 at some at some
point yeah mmm okay look aged a twosome
what I have underestimated
mmm that's not so nice okay let's start
with this rook age eight is coming yeah
what to do now rook h1 the others there
is a queen takes d5 unfortunately takes
rook takes h1 king g2 and this is this
is not really great but I can take
afford them I can cover it with rogue 84
how can I should probably go here and
try to to get something here based on e5
and Bishop takes g6 playing this very
quickly maybe I'm totally totally off in
this game but isn't this isn't this
dangerous on takes rook takes Queen
takes g6 Queen takes d5 I mean I would
say that white just winter or isn't him
but he does not need to take of course
maybe he can play I don't know Luke h8
on f8 or whatever but a threatened
Bishop f5 czechia King f8 maybe
the f8 could be a move well then i can
at least drop back to your form and just
continue but this looks still okay our
King evade King f8 can I go root leaf
I've takes on g6 and after that I don't
have a move from ma I don't really see
him check this is just flat-out losing
and then he took took how long for that
that's that strange or or or I am
overlooking something possible check
okay so we have all maybe it's not flat
out losing here but it looks a very
tricky me with the time morning I cannot
do so much with my queen here that
that's a problem no doubt you cannot get
the Queen into the tech easily Queenie
for maybe
I ok I Roxy to hear okay yeah that was
that was the faucet that's right this I
should have played anyway instead of T 6
20 seconds is the main problem I get in
I can enter a scam now with the Queen
Queen g8 on something like that the
threatened d7 here Queen Jayde is quite
substantial check check check check I of
course is playing on time of course not
not accepting a draw here and this I
should manage actually to have seconds
is quite a lotta
check check check they could have just
accepted the draw check people prefer to
check lunda the rook and play on time
checkmate even if the other side can
relatively easily manage yeah I don't
know it was it was really weird I
thought I mean Here I a probe probably
just worse yeah but then then it became
strange after e5 yeah after you five
white is in fact winning according to
the comp no no no it goes down in the
evaluation but King evade is the only
move yeah but Bishop of seven is good
after that okay I thought about this
briefly Queen takes Queen fif is very
dangerous this this looks looks very
dangerous yeah well Queen d6 coming and
King takes there is Ruby I 7 mm-hmm I
wasn't so sure okay i have i have this
chat getting the look okay it's also
winning so he really blundered into e5
after if i affirm his he's in trouble or
is there any defense after that no n
King evade is the only move with some
reason changs but here here probably I I
did something wrong check oops oh this
was a bit here I did something wrong
check hmm that's very nice but not not
not easy for a human to fight rook GCS
is very strong intending the same Shack
and I get the rope here that's very nice
Bishop g4 being the relatively best
defense
and now the deep on and Queenie 6s
decisive so this was this was much
better because I just entered so quickly
ever Brooke h1 would have been also very
easy and here it's probably it's
probably okay king's chapel and here
Luke be too seems to be wrong with this
yeah this is a perpetual right this is
the trick he took them but this is this
is a perpetual on b1 and b2 and here it
seems to be M yeah drawn as well because
Jan you just have this potential check
check but he decided to just give away
the rook try to win on time but 14
seconds I mean have a queen up yeah I
guess that's the proper punishment for
this yeah there should have been a draw
but didn't turn it didn't want to draw
prefer to lose okay thanks for watching